let's say there's some type of
standardized exam where every question
on the test has four choices choice a
choice B choice C and choice D and the
test makers assure folks that over many
years there's an equal probability that
the correct answer for any one of the
items is a B C or D essentially is a 25%
chance of any of them now let's say you
have a hunch that well maybe it is
skewed towards one letter or another
how could you test this well you could
start with a null and alternative
hypothesis and then we can actually do a
hypothesis test so let's say that our
null hypothesis is equal distribution
equal distribution of correct choices
correct choices or another way of
thinking about it is a would be correct
25% of the time B would be correct 25%
of the time C would be correct 25% of
the time and D would be correct 25% of
the time now what would be our
alternative hypothesis where our
alternative hypothesis would be not
equal distribution not equal
distribution now how are we going to
actually test this well we've seen this
show before at least the beginnings of
the show you have the population of all
of your potential items here and you
could take a sample and so let's say we
take a sample of 100 items so n is equal
to 100 and let's write down the data
that we get when we look at that sample
so this is the correct choice correct
choice and then this would be the
expected number that you would expect
and then this is the actual number and
if this doesn't make sense yet we'll see
it in a second so there's four different
choices a B C D and a sample of 100
remember in any hypothesis test we start
assuming that the null hypothesis is
true so the expected number where a is a
correct choice would be 25% of this
hundred so you would expect 25 times the
a to be the correct choice 25 times B to
be the correct choice 20
five times C to be the correct choice
and 25 times D to be the correct choice
but let's say our actual results when we
look at these hundred items we get that
a is the correct choice 20 times B is
the correct choice 20 times C is a
correct choice 25 times and D is the
correct choice 35 times so if you just
look at this just like hey maybe there's
a higher frequency of D but maybe you
say well this is just a sample and just
to random chance it might have just
gotten more D's than not there's some
probability of getting this result even
assuming that the null hypothesis is
true and that's the goal of these
hypothesis test and say what's the
probability of getting a result at least
this extreme and if that probability is
below some threshold then we tend to
reject the null hypothesis and accept an
alternative and those thresholds you
have seen before we've seen these
significance levels let's say we set a
significance level of 5% 0.05 so if the
probability of getting this result or
something even more different than
what's expected is less than the
significance level then we'd reject the
null hypothesis but this all leads to
one really interesting question how do
we calculate a probability of getting a
result this extreme or more extreme how
do we even measure that and this is
where we're going to introduce a new
statistic and also for many of you a new
Greek letter and that is the capital
Greek letter Chi which might look like
an X to you but it's a little bit
curvier and you could look up more on
that you kind of curve that part of the
X but it's a chi not an X and the
statistic is called Chi squared and it's
a way of taking the difference between
the actual and the expected and
translating that into a number and the
chi-squared distribution is well I
should really should say distributions
are well studied and we can use that to
figure out what is the probability of
getting a result this extreme or more
extreme and if that's lower than our
significance level we reject the null
hypothesis and it suggests the
alternative but how do we calculate the
chi-squared statistic here well it's
reasonably intuitive what we do is for
each of these categories in this case
it's for each of these choices
we look at the difference between the
actual and the expected so for toy say
we'd say 20 is the actual minus the
expected and then we're going to square
that and then we're going to divide by
what was expected and then we're going
to do that for choice B so we're going
to say the actual was 20 expected is 25
so 20 minus 25 squared over the expected
over 25 plus then we do that for choice
C 25 minus 25 we know where that one
will end up squared over the expected
over 25 and then finally for choice D
which is going to get us 35 minus 25
squared all of that over 25 and we are
now let's see let's if we calculate this
this is going to be negative 5 squared
so that's going to be 25 this is going
to be 25 this is going to be 0 35 minus
25 is 10 squared that is a hundred so
this is one plus one plus 0 plus 4 so
our chi-square statistic in this example
came out nice and clean this won't
always be the case at 6 so what do we
make of this well what we can do is then
look at a chi-squared distribution for
the appropriate degrees of freedom and
we'll talk about that in a second and
say what is the probability of getting a
chi-square statistic 6 or larger and to
understand what a chi-squared
distribution even looks like these are
multiple chi-squared distributions for
different values for the degrees of
freedom and to calculate the degrees of
freedom you look at the number of
categories in this case we have 4
categories and you subtract 1 now that
makes a lot of sense because if you knew
how many a s B's and C's there are if
you knew the proportions even the
assumed proportions
you can always calculate the fourth one
that's why it is 4 minus 1 degrees of
freedom so in this case our degrees of
freedom are going to be equal to 3 over
here sometimes you'll see it described
as K so K is equal to 3 so if we look at
that's that little light blue
so we're looking at this chi-squared
distribution where the degree of freedom
is three and we want to figure out what
is the probability of getting a
chi-squared statistic that is six or
greater so we would be looking at this
area right over here and you could
figure it out using a calculator or if
you're taking some type of a test like
an AP statistics exam for example you
could use their tables they give you and
so a table like this could be quite
useful remember we're dealing with the
situation where we have three degrees of
freedom we had four categories so 4
minus 1 is 3 and we got a chi-squared
value our chi-square statistic was 6 so
this right over here tells us the
probability of getting a 6 point 2 5 or
greater for a chi-squared value is 10%
if we go back to this chart we just
learned that this probability from six
point two five and up when we have three
degrees of freedom that this right over
here is 10%
well that's 10% then the probability the
probability of getting a chi-squared
value greater than or equal to 6 is
going to be greater than 10% greater
than 10% and we could also view this as
our p-value and so far probability
assuming the null hypothesis is greater
than 10% well it's definitely going to
be greater than our significance level
and because of that we will fail to
reject fail to reject and so this is an
example of even though in your sample
you just happen to get more DS the
probability of getting a result at least
as Extreme as what you saw is going to
be a little bit over 10%